ANOTHER TWO FOR McDANIELS.
HE LEADS ROUNDS.
THE BULLS ARE AT THE TOP OF THE
STANDINGS.
HE'SOVERALL.
WOULD THAT BASELINE.
LaMELO WITH GOOD D, BUT THEY
TEAM PAYTON TAKES THE FIVE-POINT
CADE IS GOING McDANIELS.
>> JADEN GOING THE OTHER WAY. M
>> I LIKE HIS GAME?E TO GET THA
TO CUNNINGHAM.
IT'S STARTING TO GET REAL R RUN
TATAKIKINGNG T THIHIS S GAGAMEM.
LET'S TAKE ANOTHER GOING TO PUS
AT THE REF.
COULD HAVE USED A CHALLENGE.
>> I DONON LAMELO.
TATE RECOVERS.
GOES TO THE LANE, AND GETS IT T
RIGHT THERE.
>> LOOK AT AND YOU CAN TELL
ALREADY DEFENSE IS ON
BANE, HE CAN HE LAY IT UP LOT OF
MINUTES IN THIS LEAGUE.
>> BEHIND YOU,
>> THAT IS A GREATHERE,
IN THETATE.
COME UP BIG IN THE CLUTCH AGAIN.
Y